let's suppose you're encountering
arrogance from someone and really what
you said before was that it was fear but
also to their ego their pride could be
hurt because they're thinking why do you
think I don't know what I'm doing which
is not really what you're saying you're
just wanting to explore more
possibilities and let them know that you
have a class and coaching available but
how can you turn it around and have it
so that they don't feel hurt that it's
about their abilities okay that's a
great question first of all we go back
to that resistance and obstacle thing we
talked about before because if I attack
them or approach that whole thing about
their arrogance and they're putting up a
wall against other possibilities it'll
the wall will get stronger so I can't do
that but if they say I know how to work
with actors I know how do I know all
that usually what I said great great
let's let's see how this goes and then
usually what happens and I've seen this
in else has seen this many times start
working with the director and they start
working with the interrogation process
two things happen very quickly first of
all they realize that the interrogation
process is difficult and that's a little
intimidating but they hang in but then
the other thing that they see is what
starts to come out of the characters and
they start to see that they are now
experiencing something way beyond what
they imagined and it probably includes
what they thought they wanted and
includes aspects of the care they want
but they start to see more they sees
such a rich terrain in front of them
that suddenly the arrogance drops away
so I rely on the power of what I'm
teaching the techniques of what I'm
teaching if I can take them through
these skills and allow them to
experience it it'll change the the is
there's another similar situation when
we get into staging which we talked
about before and when I'm doing a
workshop on staging and then directors
all right I know how to stage this thing
I said great and they'll stage it and
I'll look at it and I will think no this
much more you can explore but rather
than tell them no you haven't explored
it enough you don't get it
I very gently say okay that's that's
great and I'll say to the actor how do
you feel standing there there in the
scene look I feel fine I feel fine
Oh fine and I'll say to the director
okay she's standing there at the
beginning of the scene and how do you
want her to feel like she should feel
really insecure okay and I move the
actor a little bit to another place
I said now how do you feel this is awful
I felt terrible over there and I turned
to the director I said is that what you
want he says yeah I said well you got it
then he sees Wow you did that just by
moving her rather than argue about what
he knows and what will work and what my
job is to demonstrate to the directors
here's how this works
you can argue whether you need it or not
you can tell me but let me show you how
it works
90% of the time directors are blown away
we had a situation here yesterday with a
writer this is a slightly different
thing but not on a script and I
interrogated the writer as the main
character in the script and it took I
don't know I'll show what it was about
three five minutes five minutes five
minutes if I minutes later he first of
all if I'm his lady he was in tears as
the character he was shaking in them
tears because he was because of what the
character was experiencing and then the
writer what he was experiencing through
the character and he went oh my god and
he realized he had a whole different
movie he had a whole different scenario
now he he stuck now he starts to
understand the power of what I'm trying
to teach I could try to explain that to
him I go i I don't need that
so writers directors and actors have to
experience these techniques I can write
about it forever you can see this
interview you can watch this and go I
think I got it I think I know what he's
talking about
you could even watch the DVD that you
watch the call okay once you're in there
once you're in the room experiencing it
as writers at directors an actor any of
these techniques
then you will know it has to be
experienced Marc fine I'm hearing that
that is a word that doesn't have a good
connotation to it
what does fine me to you f ing when did
I use fine a couple times and maybe I'm
projecting my own worldview onto it but
possibly probably but I'm hearing that
fine
is not a good word to describe something
in fact it means the opposite but
someone's afraid to let someone know
that I'm not comfortable with it how are
you today huh I'm fine oh well I say
when and when if someone says I'm fine
or how was it that one scene when you
yeah fine it's fine I was a script oh
yeah we did some note you know let me
ask you this is not an interview of you
but let me ask sure when you hear
someone Karen say and you say to someone
how are you doing I'm fine fine
what are you here I hear that things are
not good but they don't want to say it
so they have to have a good a cover
that's just sort of medium yep instead
of oh I'm doing great today yep or oh
man I had a horrible time getting here
so but I'm fine they want to close it
down yep they don't want to talk so
they're closing and they're probably
saying what you're probably hearing is
yeah I'm fine I'm doing okay and I don't
want to talk in it right which makes you
think and me think there's a lot going
on there that it's uncomfortable doesn't
what she doesn't see or he doesn't want
to go there so when you say to an actor
or someone you work with how you doing
fine
there you go okay there's something
going on now if you keep pressing up
against that wall you're gonna get a lot
of resistance now your job is to let me
see can I get to it can I get find
another way and this has been my pretty
much my whole career find another way to
access the truth with that individual or
with that character with that writer
director actor or character how can I
get around the barriers that are
automatically there because we're human
beings and we put them up we protect
ourselves can I find another way
appropriately to get around that
and get to the truth not only so I can
see the truth but so that the the person
who's said fine let's say it's an actor
said I'm fine
my feeling is there's also a part of
that person who wants to reveal that you
know that's and that's their committee
that's and then there's another voice I
want to talk about it on the other
voices don't talk about it in others
there's a little war going on in there
that we all experience so if I can get
to the truth and get somehow find a way
not only so I can know more but also
said he or she can have the opportunity
to reveal it or even learn something
about themselves quite possibly okay so
fine to you doesn't mean conversations
over and it's good it means hmm think
something's wrong but I think they would
be willing to talk about it if I go
around a different way yeah and I don't
keep pushing up against doesn't sound
like things are fine yeah yeah if I do
it it doesn't sound like things are fine
then the wall it's gonna get thicker
mm-hmm yeah and it might even be someone
says something and I say something how
you doing they're fine and I go okay
we're gonna get back to that later and I
may just go off on a whole nother track
but with the intention of getting to
what's bothering them if it's an actor
since we're talking a lot about working
with actors if it's an actor then my
concern will be that whatever's really
going on with them it's going to get in
the way of their work that day if it's
an actor I'm working with that day how
you do it fine go okay we've got this
this could get in the way of the work
we're doing today and let's say I'm
picking up on resentment or anger or
fear and these are very general and
let's say it's Actos a is Ian that was
an actually I've worked with a lot and I
get this fine
I go okay there's a lot of that going on
now as we're working on the scene I
haven't addressed it at all as we're
working on a scene and I start
interrogating his character do you know
where I'll go anger resentment fear as
the
character I will allow Ian to express
whatever's going on through the
character and this is when it actually
becomes in a way a little therapeutic
and which is another whole topic because
there are therapists who have been
looking at what I'm doing and wonder we
have this if it's another form of
therapy which I will address right now
it's not it's not a form of therapy
because I've had a lot of people ask me
about this along with the hypnosis
question but the interrogation is not a
form of therapy a therapy generally is
intended to help the patient the person
the individual sort of smooth out the
edges get through life in a much more
comfortable way and deal with whatever
problems he's dealing with interrogation
is absolutely the opposite interrogation
creates chaos I create chaos inside the
characters so better that the actor as
the character has to struggle with I
want them to struggle I don't want to
smooth it out and want the actor to
experience the struggle that's going on
inside the characters so it's the it's
the opposite of therapy coming back to
your question about the fine someone's
saying fine I think we all hear that
there's a hidden feelings emotions or
truth behind that and our job as
directors is to honor that respect it
but not forget it and if we can allow
the actors especially a way to release
that through the characters even if even
if it's inappropriate for the character
at the time that may be a gift
to the actor
you